are you excited about the show i'm
thrilled
i'm thrilled when do you start well
uh before the pandemic we were gonna
finish
uh supernatural on april 5th and then
start walker
april 20th and then obviously you know
global pandemic that's
like unlike anything we've ever seen and
for several generations
um and so right now i think we're set
we're set to finish supernatural on
september 10th
and then we were supposed to start
walking around certain 23rd
but that got pushed uh because we need
more time to build i think so
it's going to be hopefully sometime in
october we start in austin
how many episodes i don't know again i
don't know
um i think it was supposed i think we
got a 13 episode pickup
don't quote me on this i probably should
know this um i think we got a 13
pickup but then i think because of
everything going on
it'll just depend as you well know and
maybe some of your
listening viewing audience doesn't know
tv shows episode tv shows usually shoot
from july to april
so if we can't start till uh october
as of now late october then if we did
the same amount of episodes we would
shoot like
into july or august which means if we
got picked up for a season two
then there would be overlap so i don't
know if
i don't know i think that's going to be
at the at the mercy of a lot of
different networks like abc
fox cbs nbc cw like i feel like they're
all gonna have to go like hey guys
let's all agree on like a 10 episode
season for 2020 like a coveted season
let's do a short season and get back to
normal moving forward but again
god knows you love to work you're just
like jensen you guys just have to work
you want to work you love acting you
love it and i love that it's great